encuentra el valor absoluto de x cuando
x es igual a 5 x es igual a menos 10 y x
es igual a menos 12 así que el valor
absoluto de algo en sí la manera en la
que se denota es más complicado de lo
que en realidad es el valor absoluto y
el valor absoluto simplemente es la
distancia de este número al cero
entonces lo escribo distancia al cero y
para ponerte algún ejemplo voy a dibujar
aquí la recta numérica entonces digamos
que aquí está el cero porque estamos
calculando la distancia de dicho número
al cero y podemos pensar en el valor
absoluto de x cuando x es igual a 5
entonces voy a sustituir a x por el 5 el
valor absoluto de 5 es la distancia del
5 al 0 entonces 1 2 3 4 5 5 es
exactamente 5 espacios a la derecha del
0 cierto por lo tanto el valor absoluto
de 5 es igual a 5 esa es la distancia
ahora vamos con
el valor absoluto de menos 10 entonces
el valor absoluto de x cuando x es igual
a menos 10 la distancia del -10 al 0 lo
que estamos calculando así que aquí voy
con menos 1 - 2 - 3 - cuatro menos cinco
menos seis menos siete menos ocho menos
nueve menos diez se me acabó la recta
entonces la extiende un poco entonces
menos 10 ahora que que tan alejado está
el -10 del 0 son 10 espacios a la
izquierda del 0 cierto por lo tanto el
valor absoluto de menos 10 es igual a 10
y en general el valor absoluto de
cualquier número será siempre un valor
positivo el valor absoluto de un número
será la versión positiva de dicho número
hagamos un ejemplo más de hecho si hay
que hacer otro ejemplo del -12 entonces
el valor absoluto de menos 12 ya de
hecho ni siquiera debemos ver la recta
numérica no es necesario simplemente
será la versión positiva del -12 así que
es igual a 12 nos nos dice que el menos
12 estados espacios
del 0 cierto así que aquí está el menos
12 contamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 y 2
espacios al 0